well I was a marketing executive prior
so I had like good knowledge and I also
was a loser so I was so I knew I knew to
navigate like social media pretty well
but before that I would go to like
parties and just get [ __ ] in front of
everyone like all the time I was like 19
and I was doing this silly little G in
front of a bunch of people
everywhere just like everywhere around
just watching like my little circle yeah
what kind of parties are these this is
just a silly little party it's just like
a century city
is it on Vine this was in the valley but
this was not for and eventually my
friends and I were like all the people
here are old and ancient so wait I
started having my own club every Friday
that's the world I didn't even know
existed you're not a silly guy you're
not a silly guy you're a good Asian boy
I know yeah well he's not that either
but now that I do and it's super
controlled and I'm responsible I get
tested every seven to ten days for
Calvin
[Laughter]